إساءة ارتكبتها كاثينا جديدة لي
قانون مورنسي لونيل حقيقة قبلية لا لكن
أفكر في 4 لقطات الويبرنوم و
أشجار الأنسولين الفكاهة تطير إليها
فكرة الحشو سبتمبر بادالونا
إشارة إلى
هاجم صباح ميشيل
مينا قد تجد واتارا شريف إدريس آل
مقام للجميع فهو يستحق مهمته
في
المملكة المتحدة هؤلاء الأغنياء المحترمين الجميلين
هاردن لديه أو الجانب بير ال عتر ل
إدارة الأب وسويوز جميعهم في العاشرة من عمرهم
هل يصنع ماكواري أو حماس التي
باتاكلان بن وودسايد وعجلات المورمون
إلى دانيال بسيني إلى سيرافين جديد
العالم الفرا cydia لكن لم يتم تصفيته
في أربع جزر الكاريبي ماساجيل
باتاكلان تعرف على أوساكا ليلى فستانك و
اهتمامات محمود عزت بعيون فريدة
الوجه و
تم بناء الموتى على عجل للعودة إليه
المصدر ولكن دانيال
[موسيقى]
ماذا يعتقدون
تمريراتنا الستة ل
[موسيقى]
قبل بضع سنوات في رحلة صعب
في القدس في ذكرى والدي
وأجدادي
أتذكر أن البلدة القديمة
استحم في ضوء بري جميل
[موسيقى]
من البلفيدير تمكنت من رؤية جدار
الرثاء وساحات المساجد
هذا مفترق طرق الأديان مثل
أخبر في الدليل
دون أن أصدق ذلك كثيرًا ضحيت من أجل
العرف لم أكن أعرف ماذا أكتب
لذلك قليلا عن طريق الاستفزاز لدي
أدخل رقم هاتفي
إذا كان الله موجودا فسوف يتصل بي بما فيه الكفاية
ثم أضع قطعة صغيرة من الورق فيها
الشقوق في الجدار من الواضح أنني
لم أتلق المكالمة أبدًا من من
إما
[موسيقى]
في 13 نوفمبر 2015 كنت كلاهما
المراقبين انقاذ الضحايا بعد ذلك
بأعجوبة
وأحب أن أصدق ذلك في تلك الليلة
ربما كان يفكر بي
[موسيقى]
نعم
نحن
أوه
أعوام
أو
دعونا ننهي الاختبار بعد الظهر
ستيوارد الآن السير دانيال
بيسي مساء الخير يا سيدي
صحفي في العالم الذي كنت فيه
ضحية نفسك في الهجمات الإرهابية
13 نوفمبر 2015 في باتاكلان
وإذا كنت، الذي صور بالمناسبة
هروب المتفرجين من باتاكلان
لقد كنت مصورًا لفترة طويلة
لقد حصلت على بطاقتي الصحفية منذ عام 1977
الآن ابنة الصحفية الفخرية
على رأي القول
لقد مررت بأفضل فترة بدونها
لا ندم ولا ندم كان عظيما لدينا
يجعل أفضل الصحف وفي الصباح
تحرير العالم بالطبع
أعتقد أنه كان من الجيد بالنسبة لي أن أطلق النار
الصفحة
لذلك دعها تذهب مع هذا الحدث
مأساوية تماما ولكن على أي حال فإنه
هناك فهرس الأوقات والذي قال لي
دفعت إلى كل هذا
[موسيقى]
13 نوفمبر و 2015 إنها صدفة
دخلت القصة بالصدفة
[موسيقى]
هذا 13 9 سنوات كان علي العودة إلى المنزل
من الراديو للاستماع إلى حفلة موسيقية
موسيقى الفيلم لأنني أحب
الكثير من ذلك
ثم لأسباب x استسلمت و
لذلك عرفت كيفية العودة إلى العمل هنا
استرح حتى يجعلني أكرر يوم الجمعة
سارة زوجتي لم تكن هناك أرض
المنعطفات في بودابست هي وحدها في باريس
وصنع هذا الفيلم مع جان هيوز
انجلادي أردت أن أرى
إنها قصة رجال شرطة تائبين
وهكذا نظرت إليه من حداد
سلام
ثم جيد في الساعة 9:40 سمعت مثل
طلقات نارية
سماع هذه الأصوات اعتقدت ذلك
كان في الفيلم
وبعد فترة سمعت أن
الطلقات لم تعد كثيرة بعد الآن
بصوت أعلى مما كانت عليه في الفيلم وانسحبت
كثير 1 ثم إنه انفجار
[موسيقى]
ثم أدركت أن ذلك كان يحدث
بل في الشارع أنت على الشاشة
ذهبت لفتح النافذة ل
يفحص
هذا هو المكان الذي قرأت فيه أنني سمعت
الطلقات ثم الناس الذين
كانوا يفرون
كانوا يصرخون في قلت لنفسي كان كذلك
شيء كبير يحدث
وبالفعل تشرح الصحيفة أنني أفعل ذلك
الصور
في البداية أعتقد أنه
تصفية الحسابات في المعركة
أرباع ولكن من أخرج مسدسا
يبدأ في الجذب فقط أمام توماس
من الواضح الفرار من الذعر
رؤية أن هذا هو، أدعو
مذكرات في الواقع كان لي أن
بينوا هوبكين رقم واحد
محرري العالم وأخبروه
الاستماع ومضات المحرز في المنزل هو
شيء خطير للغاية يحدث
الدرس
وهذا هو المكان الذي توجد فيه أودي بالفعل
عدة حوادث إطلاق نار في باريس
فيلم البندقية
[تصفيق]
ماذا يحدث
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نيورت
[موسيقى]
ما أراه فظيعًا، إنه أنا
لم يسبق لي أن رأيت من قبل أن هذا هو
أخي رأيت أنه من المدقع
عندما تفهم أن الأمر خطير للغاية
لديك هذا الوهم بالحماية
من خلف الشاشة وتشعر
محمي
[يضحك]
في مرحلة ما أنا في النافذة و
لا شيء يحدث أكثر
أرى الناس متوترة أمام
باب باتاكلان من الهواتف التي
بالتأكيد بريق الجرحى الذين
حاول الاتصال أو مات بسبب
أنهم أخرجوا هواتفهم من قبل
منعكس ولكن هناك المزيد من الطلقات هناك
لا مزيد من الصراخ
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنني لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث
داخل
بشكل غير مباشر هناك مقاومة هناك
هناك رجال أرى أنهم قتلوا
لذلك أغلق هذه النافذة
من الصعب لائقة
آخذ شاحن الهاتف I
أرتدي حذائي الذي أمارسه
أنا في القميص
تذهب إلى نهاية خطوتك ولكن
من لا يعتقد أن هذا هو من سيساعد
الناس الذين هم في أسوأ الأوقات
المواقف إما أن تؤذي دارجود
نيساند
يبدو واضحا بالنسبة لي
هو بحذر
لعب القطب أتكئ قليلا
beaurevoir أعطى بحذر لا
الذهب الأفضل موجود، وهو نفس الشيء الموجود
لا شيء يذكر صمت رهيب
معظم الجثث أمام
باب باتاكلان وهناك فقط
شخص ذو قميص أحمر قال م
حوالي عشرة أمتار على
رصيف
ذهبت إلى هناك بحذر شديد ولذلك أنا
انحنى عليه ورأى أنه
كان على قيد الحياة
وهكذا مع رجل آخر موجود
عزيزي الشارع لأنهم سيكونون كذلك
هناك ويتحقق لأن هناك ل
يتم كتابة ضربة التوأم منتصف الشارع
ومع ذلك سيتعين عليهم جذبه من أجل
وضعت في القاعة حتى لا يكون كذلك
يتعرض في حالة قيام السيدة سار بإطلاق النار و
الرجل ذو الرداء الأسود يختفي ولذا أطلقت النار
ماثيو أكثر قليلا على متر
لتكون قادرة على إغلاق هذا الباب
مثل أسافينه أدعو بنوا ل
اشرح له أن هذا ما يحدث
لدي تحت عيني وعشرات الجثث
وأخيرا الأشخاص الذين فروا من المساهمة
بالعشرات أو المئات ولكن هناك
الهوامش
لديه حرق كبير وداعا نعم
سقوط الهاتف على الأرض في القاعة
لا أعرف لماذا أفقدهم
الأحذية وأنا أفهم أن و
يزيل الرصاص ويبول الدم
أنا على علم ولكن ما زلت أحب
التي أخذناها لكمة
شيء سوف يهز أنهم يعيشون إذا
أنا أسقط أنا ميت
إذا بقيت مستيقظًا فهذا أنا
على قيد الحياة
[موسيقى]
لقد كان بينوا بريت هو من أخبرني بذلك
انتظرت وسوف تفعل سبع دقائق قبل ذلك
ألتقط الهاتف له
أقول أنني كنت على قيد الحياة
ولكن هذه اللحظة هي لإنقاذ بشرتك
لقد نزف جيدًا هناك وأنا لست ذرتي
أخذ رصاصة سيكون من الضروري أن ترتفع إلى
المستشفى وكيف
مثل هذا فهو عملاقه
لهم قميصي وأنا جعلت لنفسي واحدة
عاصبة
تفعل كما تدفع بأسنانك
ومن ناحية أخرى أخيرا جيدة دو
من الواضح تمامًا أنه جيد أنا كذلك
قيل لي أنني سأتصل بجارتي
برونو وستليس الذي يعيش في الرابع
أن يأتي ويساعدني
[موسيقى]
نحن
لقد وعدنا بأن نكون
غادر قبل عيد الميلاد
أنت فقط تريد أن تنفق شيئا
كل شيء في ويندهوك لا يتحول
اسم انها حقا الكثير من المتاعب له
أخبرني أنه لا يستطيع تحمل المزيد من هذا
مرور نعتقد أنه حتى اليوم
عندما نعود فهو يفضل تجنبه
فهو يرى أشياء لا أراها
لم أر أي وفيات صحفية ولم أرها
الصور التي سوف تهيمن بالصدمة
أكثر ما يطاردني هو الرجل
الذي ركض الجزء الخلفي من رأسه ذلك
يغلق
في الأسابيع القليلة الأولى لكل منهما
مرات تمر في شارع فوكو
شرق
أنا لم أخبر أحدا هنا
وأعتقد أن هذا ما أردت
اسمع هذا ما كنت أبحث عنه
الانتقال إلى الخارج
أوه
سوف ننسى ذلك العمدة لكنه في هذه العملية
لتمرير من تنهدات الصدمة
[موسيقى]
[يضحك]
هذا الجمعة الثالث عشر كنت قد حددت يومي
لقضاء بعض الوقت مع كليمنت
كان هناك مخرج 10 في الصيف في المتحف
بيكاسو في نفس الصباح
[موسيقى]
كانت لابنتنا الكبرى في الصف
الطبخ مع المدرسة لذلك كان عليها أن تفعل ذلك
العودة يوم السبت
شاهدت المباراة على شاشة التلفزيون هناك
أقيمت المباراة على ملعب فرنسا كلها
أتذكر
[تصفيق]
الى
و ال
انفجار خلال مباراة لكرة القدم
انفجار أخيرا
الطفرة المتوقعة ثم سمعنا
المعلقين الذين يقاطعون و
الذي يتساءل أيضًا عما يحدث
نفس المشكلة
فكرت في المنتج الذي
سلام أنطونيو كان لديه رجال أ
واصلت اللعب مع فرنسا
في وقت ما في الشارع سمعنا
ضجيج بدا وكأنه ضجيج
آلات ثقب الصخور
ثم سمعنا خلفنا بسرعة كبيرة
صراخ الناس يصرخون
لذلك هرعنا إلى النافذة نحن
شاهدت ما كان يحدث
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أفكر على الفور في الإخوة
كواسي شارلي إيبدو وأنا أقول ذلك لنفسي
هذا هو
وتشارلي إيبدو هذه الشوارع الثلاثة
بعيد
نحن نفهم أنه هجوم
بالنسبة لي إنه مثل مشهد سينمائي
هبوط الناس يركضون
تحت الشظايا
لدي طفلي الذي ينام وهو يعلم
كان عمره في الواقع خمس سنوات في ذلك الوقت
أستطيع أن أرى ذلك
[موسيقى]
لكي أتصل بمركز الشرطة
من يجيبني سيدتي لا نستطيع أن نقول لك
مساعدة وهكذا هناك جوستين رجل مضت
طلقات خلال باتاكلان مالين هناك
طلقات في كل مكان في باريس، وهناك
إطلاق النار على باتاكلان في باتاكلان أنت
على البخار حيث أعيش فوق أنا
نرى هناك الناس يركضون
في الشارع وهناك سمعته يقول ذلك
أطلق النار على باتاكلان لذا أقفل الخط
في الواقع يقولون أنهم لا يعرفون
ليس لدينا أي فكرة عن حجم هذا
هذا هو
الآن وهاتفي يرن
وهي فيرونيك الجارة في الطابق السفلي
من أخبرني أنني لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث
مررت بما أستطيع أن أصعد إليك
أنا في انتظار Véronique Mint وهكذا
خلال هذا الوقت نحن مجمدون أمام
التلفزيون هناك لافتات التمرير من خلال
الشاشة التي تعلن عن الهجمات
أنا مشلولة وأقف بلا حراك
لا أعلم ماذا يحدث فأنا أ
قطعة من الخشب في ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
أقفز وهي التي تلتقط
افتح لي أنا مجروحة سألت
انها هنا ولكن هذا العام أنا
يؤلمني تعال وافتحني
وعلى حادث ويشترط لدانيال
من سقط ومن أصيب
لا أعتقد غريزية جدا وهناك
أنا خائف لأنه فجأة
إنه اتصال مباشر مع الخارج
لا يزال الوضع على ما يرام
مخيف وكنت خائفا حتى الموت
لم أكن لأضع نفسي في خطر
إذا لم يتصلوا بي
[موسيقى]
عندما نزلت إلى الطابق السفلي رأيت دانييل من
واقفاً من يمسك بذراعه وعنده
قدم الرجل الذي وجهه لأسفل
ومن هو في حمام دم حقا
ضحك الدم في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
ومن يقول لدانيال باس بين اللقطات
يصعد المصعد إلى الطابق الرابع
بقي يانكيز هناك استدرت و
أرى فيرونيكا وهي في الطابق السفلي
أيضا
لا أعرف لماذا تبعتني
لا أتوقع ذلك
[موسيقى]
في الممر لي كنت هناك منذ ذلك الحين
حوالي 15 سنة
انها ليست معروفة جيراني لا
على الفور
إنه معروف حقًا في المساء
الرقص في ظروف مضحكة
[موسيقى]
واجهت مشكلة في الانتقال من كريم باتا
في الواقع تحدثت عن أشياء أخرى ولكن
لا باتاكلان
في مكان ما لقد تأثرت به
جسديا ولكن القواعد في الحياة
أصبحت باريس معقدة للعيش فيها
لي
بما في ذلك سنتين حتى لو كانت هناك متابعة
نفسي
أعتقد أن أعود قبل الليل
إنه يقلقني ويقلق الآخرين في الخارج
الليل
ويتعلق الأمر بالاعتراف بهم كضحايا
كما ترى كانت أهميتها بالنسبة ل
إعادة الإعمار
[موسيقى]
أنا أتجاوز في الواقع على الإطلاق هناك
قبل ساعات قليلة من وصولي
الغريب وG2 بسيط
[موسيقى]
لي كان
شهرين ونصف كنت فيها
التصوير في المغرب
موجود في مسلسل تلفزيوني
تعاملت مع الجغرافيا السياسية والتجسس
صناعي
كان لدينا العديد من المنتجات المقلدة
في هذه السلسلة الكثير من الماكياج
المؤثرات الخاصة للأشخاص المصابين
وهي تبادل لاطلاق النار
الذي أعدني له في مكان ما
تاريخ بيادق باتا
[موسيقى]
أين يجب أن ينتهي شيء ما بإطلاق النار
مثل 17 نوفمبر، لذلك كان علي أن أكون كذلك
ولا يزال في المغرب في ذلك الوقت وفي
وضع مجلد أدخل 13 أ
قبل ساعة من حدث باتاكلان
[موسيقى]
وكان الأمر مذهلاً جدًا لأنه 20
بعد وصولي إلى باتاكلان وأعتقد
بالضبط نفس الشيء، وهناك هو عليه
أكثر وهمية
[موسيقى]
2 شيء من هذا القبيل من قليلا
خاصة حيث ما رأيته أنا
يمكن في مكان ما أ
عقلي يقبل ذلك
أتقبل ما كنت أراه
لأنني رأيت ذلك من قبل
[موسيقى]
عندما وصلت إلى المنزل هو
كان مثل الساعة 8:30 مساءً.
كنت على سريري قمت بالتوصيل
حتى وأنا نائم سأستفيد منه استفادة كاملة
وصولي غدا أنا متعب أنا
الذهاب إلى النوم
ثم بدأت أسمع أ
الضوضاء في الشارع ما تستطيع
أسمع ذلك بانتظام ولكني أقول لنفسي
إذا كان غريبا هذا الحفل نزهة
انها ليست تماما كالمعتاد
نهضت وذهبت إلى المستوى
من المطبخ لمشاهدة ما هو
كان يمر في الشارع هناك بدأت
وقتا طويلا للصراخ
لكن
[موسيقى]
ما حدث في ذلك الوقت هو
أننا
نفهم ما يحدث ونحن نفهم
لا شيء في نفس الوقت
لقد وجدت نفسي ملتفًا
في الحماية لعدم المعرفة
ما كان يحدث حقا الذهب ل
في الخارج وجدت مثل هذا
احمينا وسمعت الصندوق
برونو في الماء ولذا اتصلت بهم
[موسيقى]
طالما
لقد دخلت في العمل مع
برونو عندما نزلنا
شهر من ذلك الوقت
الشعور بأنني حصلت عليه كان أبعد من ذلك
نشعر أن الانعكاس
ركز فقط على شيء واحد لمساعدة هؤلاء
الذين يعانون
عندما وصلت إلى الطابق السفلي دعها تفعل ذلك
الدم في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
أتذكر أنني رأيته يقول ذلك
ليس من الممكن أن نرى هذا الرجل لا يمكن
لا تفعل كل هذا الدم الذي هو رجل
لا يحتوي على العديد من الأصوات، فهذا مستحيل
لي
فصعد كلاهما وأنا
وجدت نفسي في الطابق السفلي وحدي مع
هناك هذا الرجل الذي كان له الوجه
ضد البلاط والليالي
في كل مكان
كان لديه ساق مطبوعة بالكامل
مع بركة كبيرة من الدم
ووضعت يدي على كتفها و
أنا قريب بعض الشيء، لا يزال الأمر كذلك
لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا يتفاعلون ولأن في
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن لديه على الإطلاق
يتفاعل ثم تحرك قليلا
علية
وإذا قلت شيئًا واحدًا فقد كان
خاصة أنني لا أتذكر أنني قلت
يبدو لطيفا حقا أنك ذاهب
قضاء المساء مع الماء
[موسيقى]
عندما أعود إلى أسفل في هذا الوقت أنا
تلتقي بفيرونيك التي صعدت إلى هذا المستوى
ما في وسعهم في أي الرابع قبل
دانيال
[موسيقى]
لذلك عندما يكون لدي قتال فهو كبير
كان ولكن لأنه عن طريق الضوء
تلقائي أقول لنفسي إذا كان مطلق النار من
هم في الشارع وهم ذاهبون لرؤية
ضوء سوف يأتون وهكذا الخميس في
ماثيو لم يبق هناك، علينا أن نختبئ
أعتقد أنه مرتبط بالمأوى
فيشكرني
في فرنسا مثالية
وعلى الفور يقول شكرا لك بعد ذلك
لم أفعل شيئًا من أجلنا بعد
إنها ملاك أحبك
في ذلك الوقت أعتقد أنه كان كذلك
مرتاح جدًا وهكذا نعم ولكن تم ذلك
بيان في العالم
بالنسبة لي، تم الانتهاء من الجزء الأصعب ولكننا
سوف تكون قادرة على تحصين أنفسهم وترسيخ أنفسهم مغلقة
الباب مغلق ولكن في تلك اللحظة أنا
خوفي ما يدخلون الجزيرة
[موسيقى]
نحاول الاتصال بقسم الإطفاء
لقد حاولت الاتصال بالسامو الذي نتصل به مرة أخرى
مراكز الشرطة يأخذون العنوان
يأخذون إلى الأسماء التي تعرف أ
مرور سانت بيير أميلوت في 14 مايو
لا أعرف إذا كان بإمكاننا الوصول إليك
اعتصموا
دانيال مضطرب للغاية
يأخذ هاتفه ويتصلون بهم
انظر أنهم يبحثون عن شاحن
لأنه قال في نفسه أنه قد ذكر
بطارياتها المشكلة هي أن لدي
هذا الفيديو وأنا لا أستطيع
شحنه
بالنسبة لي عندما رأيت ذلك هناك، وكان
كان لديه صحفي حربي
يجب أن يتم تمرير الصورة إلى
زملائي أتذكر أنني
كان يفعل ولكن هذا الرجل لا يستسلم
بسبب الإصابة التي تعرض لها
كما أعتقد في حالة صدمة ومع
جرعة من الأدرينالين لا يستطيع تناولها
حتى انه في كل مكان يتحدث
قوية جدا جدا
يتذكر مكان الثلاثاء في تونس الصوت الذي
أنا أخرجك
لن تحلم يا ابني هناك، لا يجب عليك ذلك
دعهم يرون ذلك
وعلى العكس من ذلك ماثيو الذي أطال
بلا حراك كل شاحب
نحن أقل قلقا بشأن مظهر
إصابة دانيال أكثر من إصابة ماثيو
الذي تقيأ
يبدو الجرح قبيحًا جدًا
اسأل لوس الشيء القبيح جدا
وكانت فكرتنا أن نجعله يتحدث
يعلم أنه ينتقل إلى جوجل الذي
الأمريكي الذي نحن سبتمبر لنا
يقول أنه كان بالفعل في نيويورك
وأعتقد أنه كان يتجول في الواقع لدي
عشر حالات محتملة أن الخبز كان لديهم
هجومين ولا حياته
[موسيقى]
منذ فترة تعادلين في حوالي الساعة 11 صباحًا
بدأت أشعر أنك تضعف
ما أضعف ذلك
جسديا أنت تدعم نفس و
كلما زاد إيماننا دعنا نقول نقيًا و
كان على الأبرياء أن يفعلوا ذلك
[موسيقى]
تذكر أنه أحضر لي الديزل لكني أستطيع ذلك
لا تموت، لا أريد أن أموت، عليك أن تفعل ذلك
دعني أقول لك شيئا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما كنت مستلقيا على الأرض كان الأمر كذلك
اليائس أيضًا هو ثلاثة فقط
قبل أسابيع كنت قد تزوجت
ساره
تم جمع كل الأصدقاء كل
أصدقاء العائلة كان هناك ابني
إيلي الذي جاء كان جدا
تتحرك وعلى هدفنا ولكن
كيف سأفعل لقد تزوجت
سأموت
[موسيقى]
كان قلقي الكبير
اسأل كما الرصاص من جسده آدم
لأن رؤية 10 قدم هو مثل
قلت لنفسي ولكن الأوقات
لو كنت أعرف أنه كان فقط لو ليل
سيكون بالذعر لأن سيلي من جانبه
الحياة ماذا
لذلك أردت أن أمرر إبهامي و
جعله نقطة ضغط تحت
الإبط في الواقع وعندما أضع بلدي
اثنان فقط أتذكرهما تحت ذراعه
وشعرت أنني يجب أن أذهب إليها
إصابة في الظهر
وهذا الشعور يبقى معي
قوية حقا أن تشعر بهذه الطريقة
لعق اللحم وحرارة
مجال
[موسيقى]
تقول أنك سوف تموت ولكن ما هو؟
ما يجب القيام به لفتحه
وهو خلافا لما يقولون تذهب
يتحدى الدولة قراءة وبالإضافة إلى ذلك أنا
أخبرني [ __ ] هناك للمباراة حيث كل
زيت الكافور له وهذا هو المكان الذي لديه
لا تخرج أبدا
وليل ذلك المساء كان ابني فيه
لعبة كرة القدم الدراما الجانبية لسماء الشتاء
فرنسا نفسها
نعم لقد عاش دائمًا هنا وهو معه
كان من الممكن أن يكون جيدًا في أصدقائه
مقهى باتاكلان لمشاهدة المباراة
اتصلت بهم على الفور تقول لك
لا تخرج وابق في المقهى في ديكي
إذا كان هذا هو جهازه هناك شيء
باتاكلان معقد جدًا لكنك لا تفعل ذلك
لا تتحرك من مقهى السيرك الذي تقيم فيه
هناك وذلك أنه سوف يتذكر كاملا
من س
اتبعت ونعم أنا مجروح هناك
أنا في انتظار المساعدة للعب أقول ذلك
ويقول لي
أبي لا يغادر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاتجاه على الفور إلى باتاكلان حيث
وسمع طلقات نارية حولها
قاعة أنطوان فيجناو للحفلات الموسيقية
على الفور هبوب
كلاشينكوف واثنين من المعايير
إنقاذ التفجيرات قبل بضع سنوات
دقائق تشبه انفجارات
قنابل يدوية حدث لعدد قليل
عشرات الأمتار من هنا بالتوازي
سمعتهم مؤخرًا مرة أخرى
بعض التفجيرات خاصة في
الشوارع التي تقع خلف باتاكلان
في اتجاه السيرك الشتوي
في وقت ما كان منتصف الليل فقط
لذلك كان لا يزال ساعتين
نحاول الاعتراف بذلك
كان هناك هناك تحت العالم المسموع أخيرًا
كانت المصاريع مغلقة إلا أنت
لا أرى أننا سمعنا الضجيج هناك
كانت الجدران تهتز
لقد كان لصالح أصوات
كلش من الحيل التي أطلقت الريح من الجميع
الجانبين
لقد كانوا فيرونيك إستل
مستنسخة ضد جدار الرعب
لقد كان إرهابًا حقيقيًا في دبي، أليس كذلك؟
أن هذا الاهتمام وترجمته من
تم ترويع الإرهاب
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي إذا نجوت من مدخل
المبنى الذي لن أموت فيه
نحن نعلم أن الشرطة هناك
سماع صفارات الإنذار نسمع
انفجارات ولكن بعد ذلك في مرحلة ما أكثر
لا شئ
لذلك ننتظر قليلاً وفي مرحلة ما
أجد النافذة وهناك أرى أ
طوق الشرطة موجود هناك
لذا اتصل لرؤيتي وموراتي
لذلك أنا هنا مثل يد العون
أقولها مرة أخرى، لدينا أشخاص مصابون هنا
في اللعبة
دخلوا القاعة
لقد تمكنت من اصطحابه إلى القفص
من الدرج الذي نزلت إليه
اترك المصعد لماثيو
أخبار و
هيا على غطاء محرك السيارة الخاص بي fascht بدون قميص في 101
وكان على عربتي في الثانية
و
أقول له انتظر المباراة وأنا هنا
يؤذي
كان يعتقد أنني إما قناص أو
الإرهابي الهارب الذي كان على
سقف
لقد نعم إنه هراء تام
إنه ذعر كبير مثل ومارك
لا أحد يعرف ما كان يحدث
ورجال الشرطة السريين ولكن دع الماضي و
لحسن الحظ لا أعرف أنه سيكون
الماضي هنا إذا تعرضت لإطلاق النار بسبب
أن هناك ارتباك في الأمام و
لدغ كبير
أنت تقول أن كل شيء سيء ولكن هذا كل شيء
الكمال هناك معجزة
في تلك اللحظة خرجت من الجحيم
العالم وهذا هو لي كانت المرحلة
i/ii بطريقة معينة
حسنا، أنا في أيدي
الأطباء يحدد ببساطة أن لدي
كل دور الأعصاب وهذا يجعل
تأثير الانفجار في ذراعي
وبعد ذلك عندما كنت أكثر من ذلك بقليل
استيقظت في السراويل وبعض
الأرز المخدر وماثيو ما هو
أنه أصبح لأنني لم أفعل ذلك
عنه لم أكن أعرف على الإطلاق ما هو
أصبح
جعله القدر اثنين
الغرف أخيرًا كنا بجوارها وها نحن هناك
وجدت نفسي ذهبت لأرى لأن
أن أستطيع المشي
[موسيقى]
فجأة خضع لعملية جراحية على المختار
سوف يسقطون وقد قيل لهم ماذا
هذا ترك جيدًا لا وحصل علي
وقال كيف خرج من
الغرفة لأنه لم يحالفه الحظ
على ظهره وأصيب
كان يحاول المواعدة في فكرته
كان جيدا لا يمكن أن تعمل ولكن
خاصة وأن هناك الكثير من الناس
عليه
على باب الطوارئ عن طريق صغير
العطلة وحتى تتمكن من الاستمرار
فوضع أصابعه بشكل ظاهر
مدمن مخدرات من قوة اليأس
أطلق النار ولكن الرجال الذين كانوا على
مزق كل عضلاته
مرة أخرى كثيرا انه سحب تمكن من ذلك
اخرج منه
تدحرج على الرصيف المقابل
أن لا يكون في الحشد، وبالتالي فهو
انتهى حيث أنا الأسعار
الدائرة كاملة في الحقيقة ليست كذلك
ليست مغلقة لأنها تبدأ
شيء آخر يهرب مني تمامًا
هذا هو الجانب الإعلامي
وهناك يحصل على الكثير
في هذا الجنون الإعلامي
لديك كل أجهزة التلفاز، كل الصحف
من العالم اجمع
وهناك ترس يبدأ
المكان الذي يصعب إدارته للغاية
لقد عملت دائمًا في الظل
وهناك سوف تضيء مع
السيرك الإعلامي
قلت لنفسي على أي حال الفيلم
سيكون بمثابة وثيقة الأدلة و
ثم ربما لا ولكن على أية حال
سيكون هذا أحد الأشياء التي ستحدث
سمع شيء الصحفيين
وشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي تشهد على ذلك.
سلاسل هطول كامل هذا
الفورية لا تزال للغاية
تنتهك كل المشاعر التآمرية
وأخيرا حدث كل شيء مع الإهانات
حتى يظهر في اليوم التالي أن
كانت الصور أشياء
فهل كان لا بد من البث أو
ليست هذه الصور إنه سؤال إذا كنت
أعتقد ذلك لأننا نخدم
شهادات هذه الحقائق
هناك من الصعب كصورة ولكنه
واقع لا نستطيع أن ننكره
وهو الدليل بالصورة أيضًا
ليقول أن الشهادات هشة
إذا لم أر الصور
كنت سأقول أن الناس سقطوا
واحدة تلو الأخرى بالضربات
من النار وخاصة أنه كان هناك
المرأة الحامل شنق فناث الذي
كان على استعداد للسقوط راي بشكل شرعي
يتحدى شهاداتنا
للصور هنا يذهب من
تعليق
حتى لو مع المشتقات حول هذا
فيديو النخبة وحقائق ولكن
الحقائق عنيدة وهذا ما حدث
يمر
لم أكن ضحية
علاوة على ذلك، لم أعتبر نفسي كذلك
ضحية
لقد خرجت منه بأعجوبة
جيد إلى حد ما، لذلك كان ذلك أفضل بكثير، وبالتالي
أواصل حياتي
عمري 20 عامًا هو 62 عامًا، إنها حياتي
هنا لذلك فهو شيء مهم
إنها مليئة بالذكريات الجيدة جدًا
ذكريات ذكريات قاسية جدا جدا
صعب
بالنسبة لي كان أيضًا شكلاً من أشكال
المقاومة الأمر متروك للجميع
سأل ولكن لم ينتقل إلى شينون
seilhac إذا انتقلت وهو الذي
فوز تياو ما سأهرب مني مكانا
وهو ملكي الذي استثمرته
بنيت وهذا يعني أنهم
سأفوز بذلك حتى لو كان لدي متى
حتى لو كان في النادي الذي نأتي فيه
هم في منزلي
[موسيقى]
ولي كربتي التي ارتفعت
في كثير من الأحيان كان بالفعل أنا فتح
باب منزلي وهناك القاتل الذي
يقتلني وكان يطاردني بما فيه الكفاية
على طول
كان الأمر صعبًا ولكنه كان بالمناسبة
من كل ما تمكنت من تجميعه
هذا المساء من الجار الذي يعتقد
أن هناك قاتل قادم
في القاعة ونحن بخير
ولذا كان عليه أن يعمل وكل ذلك و
بالفعل كانت هناك هذه الصدمة
أنه لم يعد موجودا الآن ولكن الذي
هل سأقتل
[موسيقى]
لدي كل الأوسمة التي احترقت
يرمي الإصبع أنني أغني أكثر من ذلك
يؤلم ما يلسع كأنك
لدغ بشكل دائم من قبل الآلاف من
النفط في كل من الأصابع و
ضمور العضلات
عندما يكون مزعجا قليلا بسببي
أحببت العزف على الجيتار
لا أستطيع الاختيار
[موسيقى]
أوه
لقد تغيرت حياتي في 13 نوفمبر لأنه
لقد حدث حدث أساسي
[موسيقى]
وأنا أغادر هنا ليس بسبب الـ13
نوفمبر 2013 9 سنة هو جزء مني
شقة
في المأساة أو كان هناك على أي حال
السعادة العظيمة
إنها حياة يعيشها الجميع أيضًا
مع صعودا وهبوطا الخ الأشياء
الجميل أقل جمالا
[موسيقى]
لقد عشت حياتي حتى بلغت العشرين من عمري
المراهقون أخيرًا يغادرون بعد ذلك
حياتي البالغة ثم الحياة الثالثة
في 60
تزوجت ولدي طفل
ما الحظ
بالطبع هناك صدمات.
ولكن شيئا
أنا لا أفعل ذلك بشكل سيء للغاية
[موسيقى]
نحن
م
[موسيقى]
أفكر أحيانًا في تلك الرحلة
لقد فعلت في القدس
[موسيقى]
لقد ضحيت للعرف في
إيداع الكلمة التي كان لي
أدخل رقم هاتفي الخلوي
إذا كان الله موجودا فسوف يدعوني رفيقا
يوم الخميس
[موسيقى]
بالطبع لم يتصل بي قط
وأنا أحب أن أعتقد أن هذا 13
نوفمبر 2015 الساعة 10:01 مساءً عندما الحب
نحى ضدي وأخيراً نشرني
[موسيقى]
أفضل م
الى
في حركته
[موسيقى]